hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the yog
now the yog is they kind of choose your
own adventure style game where anything
is possible I need to pick two
characters and I'm going to take them
with me on an adventure through whatever
the hell the yog is because that's as
far as I know so I am gonna peg I'm
gonna pick oh that guy with the beard
the mutton shops on that guy Lu and I'm
gonna take red lady got it I got a team
I'm good to go
I'm already ready you don't need to
serenade me anymore
the yog will be here in six weeks and no
one expects it not a one of us we just
keep on living our lives week by week
unaware okay so is the yog monstrous
entity that's gonna consume all of life
as we know it ooh Oh woo physique
finesse mind charm magic and wealth I
don't know I think this guy needs to
spend his time in the tavern bartending
he seems like oh do you spend the week
serving drinks at the tavern you were in
one wealth and hips and came to charm
one day a bard pulls out his loose in
the bar and starts playing cool
unfortunately his singing is horrible in
his ruining the taverns atmosphere well
ok you decided to do something about it
oh so this is where it's like a
choose-your-own-adventure type deal ami
told me about this one who's really
excited about it so I could convince him
to leave but I could challenge him to a
loot duel because apparently like what
are the odds I'm gonna be any worse come
on bring it on you borrow the bar owners
Luke and challenge the bar do a musical
duel you only just start playing the
lute when you realize that you're even
worse than the ball hog
come on the bard easily out plays your
emotions for you to lay down your flute
just like a passive-aggressively hey
come on now I may not be a professional
but you need to just get the [ __ ] out of
here because there's horrible
you can sell there a couple people
snickering at you right now embarrassing
you lose one well well damn it I'm off
to a great start here all right so I
guess lady red she seems like she
belongs in the palace Oh a can the ball
oh you spend the week attending fancy
gatherings oh what a burdensome week oh
how will I get through it you gain to
charm in one finesse one day you decide
to lean up against the wall just to take
a break it rotates as you apply pressure
and you stumble down a set of stairs you
enter a large dusty room filled with
barrels it's on the Kings famous wine
cellar host a secret party Oh what
better way I'm sure the king will
forgive me all your friends show up and
begin the drinking when you come to you
find yourself in a home you don't
recognize and only your underwear your
clothes and hair to be found and you
seem to be the only one home what
happened all sounds like a fun time they
say the last time it came to yaagh
devoured houses hole stole lives tore
families and family members apart but I
was so very long ago okay I'm a little
bit more worried about this yaagh than I
previously was were all right so the
other thing that this guy does when he
goes out and Lumberjacks in the woods
all by him - oh hell yeah chops would
been weak cutting down trees for the
village began to physique and earn
yourself one well one day during your
forest recursions you stumble upon a
swarm of rats at first you jump
backwards in shock but then you start
hearing them conversing with one another
they call you over excuse me sir
one of them says in a high-pitched voice
do you think you might be able to help
us out with something you see we're just
trying to elect our new leader but it
seems our votes are completely tied
we're trying to decide between seedpods
the vengeful and blight tooth the wise
seed pot steps forward if you vote for
me the rats will have a powerful leader
one that isn't afraid to take our fight
to the enemy proclaims seed paw like two
steps up if you vote for me good sir I
will lead these rats to an age of
enlightenment
says blade to the tribe do you choose I
don't know maybe it's not about what I
do but maybe if I take it from my
favorite movie ratatouille I'm gonna
assume that whenever talking rats decide
to show themselves to me that they
probably shouldn't be vindictive and
vengeful because that would probably
lead to a lot of pain around the world
tomatillos blight dude half the rats
roar with tiny applause I just thought
of I thought of that Mouse that house
haha from that dough lab video I did
algae alright anyway he popped out his
head and walks back into the mass of
rats blight to climbs on your shoulder
whispers ancient secrets in your ear and
thanks Thank You platoon you can one
mind and one magic well that worked out
a little better than last time I'm gonna
go to the garden have a good time
meditating you spend the week in deep
meditation boy this lady has a rough
time going through this week preparing
for the ugh you gained one magic into
nine to one day on your way home from
the park you come across a golden ring
in the grass where the ring it might be
chanting chanted or cursed I'm gonna go
with wearing it upon placing the ring on
your finger orange markings around the
bend the markings unravel themselves the
rings were all in front of you they form
into what appears to be a fully armored
ghost radiating a beautiful orange light
it goes turns even nods before walking
away the ring looks good on you hey all
right then I should mention that this is
all randomly generated so these outcomes
probably are sporadic or maybe it's not
all randomly generated but you know what
I mean it was on us in a heartbeat
so the stories go the earth shook the
air went still okay then time to fight
in the arena I'm gonna fight not compete
or bet you spend the week fighting
brutes in the arena you getting to
physique and one finesse while wandering
around the halls between matches you
spot your former lover Kelly an awkward
exchange happens in which you want to
know how they're doing without seeming
to care
too much after a few minutes Jean one of
the most popular fighters in the arena
butts into the conversation hey Kelly
sorry to interrupt you babe but we got
to leave right now if we want to make it
to your mother's in time you know to not
bang cuz that'd be weird in front of
your mom you saying awkward goodbyes
they walk off holding hands how do you
feel I feel happy I'm happy for hoping
house burns down but I'm happy he feels
good that both of you moved on it's
encountered despite awkward this is
refreshing
you gained one charm hell yeah oh yeah I
do
hell yeah I do all right time to go to
the tavern and drink you spend the
entire week getting wasted gave you time
and once a week they are very first day
of the week when you walk through the
tavern doors everyone cheers apparently
during your last drunken outing you were
a party animal while you blacked out
yeah oh yeah I was legend spreads of
your party hard spirit game future hell
yeah man little lady can do no wrong and
then the world was howling fury chaos
the sound of all we knew being pulled in
Hannah well that's that darken ominous
all right I'm its man time to go to the
slums and fight crime
you spend the week outsmarting and
beating up criminals game one mind one
physique one finesse hell yeah one night
a small child approach with you with his
hand cupped and out surging toward fresh
toward you it's a trap beat him up he
doesn't say anything but looks up at you
with wide eyes waiting expectantly punch
the [ __ ] out of them fine I'll do it
you taught them a sack of coins you lose
one well he thanks you and walks away
the next night you recognize him on the
street spot I'm eating what looks like a
fresh loaf of bread he sees you in
smiles you feel good about yourself all
my muscles have gone I can't believe it
and one finesse and one minor one charm
oh I'll do it good whatever these things
mean barely I'm doing good
all right he'll go to the alchemy tower
let's brew a potion and maybe some booze
along with it you spend a week
experimenting with different potion
brews you get into magic one mind when
they a swarm of rats inside the building
dividing everything in the way everyone
else in the building please immediately
for you to blast them with magic glass
them with is it slither pause heed pause
it seed pawn his gang unruly after
losing the election about a blaster you
wave your hands and threw kids produce a
bouquet of flowers
that wasn't the spell you meant to cast
the rats by your attempt to exterminate
them and getting fighting you horribly
I'll by physique man to escape another
rats all over the tower well that didn't
go so well things were going well but oh
well when it arrived this time how will
be fair will we once more rebuild and
move on be strong or have we forgotten I
don't know I don't know I just don't
know okay so this guy's got gall the
palace to do administrative work cuz
that's the kind of guy he is
you spend the week doing paperwork you
paid to wealth and game one mind one day
the court jester approaches you would
you like to learn to jog really yeah
it's exciting to me please you haven't
hang on no first of all Tom maybe he
doesn't know how to juggle
maybe there's a trap sure why not you
spend the day with the Jester practicing
your juggling technique you improve
dramatically
you game to finesse another finesse you
happily pay the debts referral services
you lose one well well that's not a bad
girl things out of the hospital tend to
patients you spend the week diagnosing
and tending to the sick you get into
mind and earn one wealth one day you
hear spooky sound echoing through the
hospital soon afterwards of glowing blue
ghosts floats down from the ceiling she
seems to be wandering the house a messy
howling out horrible noises she doesn't
appear to realize that she's freaking
everyone's old I just threw up in my
mouth a little bit cuz it was so spooky
he decided to do something about it talk
calmly to the ghost you approach the
spirit and try to explain how to her the
effect she's having on the sick she
seems to understand what you're telling
her and apologizes for bothering
buddy she walks through a wall and has
never seen from again
a doctor tosses you a sack of coins at
the way of things saying things you game
to well hey the yog it's almost here
almost almost ooh looky it's getting
spooky up in here all right man you
gotta go let's go for a hunt let's go
for a good old hunt you spend the week
hunting defenseless creatures like a
good person I am you game to finesse and
sell the pelts for one well one day you
come across a group of people in the
woods from the expression on their faces
they appear to be lost help them don't
rob them you can fund the group and try
to help them find their way back into
town with ease you lead everyone back to
town extremely grateful the group gives
you a small token of their appreciation
you get into wealth Wow for a guy that's
been giving away his wealth left and
righty
he certainly has a lot of wealth all
right lady time to go it's the end of
the world so what do you do yeah hell
yeah one day an impromptu drinking
contest is held oh that sounds like my
kind of thing you down pine after pine
drinking as if your life depends on it
you end up blacking out again when you
come to you you find yourself in a home
you don't recognize only your underwear
goes are nowhere to be found
you seem to be the only one home what
happened Oh another good time whoo [ __ ]
the storm arrives in the night by the
morning it still rages two three full
days the tempest puts us through a
grinder drowns us crushes us ruins us
but then it ends we see the graveyard
our home has become a home does anything
yet live is it are we past saving oh
[ __ ] whoa
choose the roll won't even know that
means was there mean I don't know I
don't know but I think this guy is gonna
be the smelter
hell yeah you volunteer to smell your
now useless coins into building
materials okay with the modest amount of
riches you have you managed to provide a
significant amount of income you melt it
all down and with the Smiths take it and
work on various tools and building
materials this helps a survival effort a
lot you lose three wealth all right then
oh she's got a lot of charm she should
be leader I vote for a government that
lets everyone party in black outage much
as they want to without getting judged
for their actions no such thing as past
mistakes only the future but for me you
take it upon yourselves to be the leader
of the survivors you expertly delegate
and prioritize tasks you give motivating
speeches act as an effective mediator in
disputes it helps the rebuilding efforts
significantly I know I know and so we
said about our tasks once more living
our lives this time in a way we might
have never expected or wanted but in the
end it was a struggle but a struggle we
never abandoned though our home had been
stripped apart we did not let it
languish whether we succeed or fail we
did our best
who knows if the yard will visit us
again who knows if we will ever be can
ever be ready for it
that was cool it was cool it was really
cool we rebelled we did it through
drinking and partying we did with the
old tavern owner dying in the yog you
decided to take on the task before long
the taverns busier than ever filled with
good music games and friends to have
ensuing so great but every other tavern
in the area has closed down
you started to chain the taverns
throughout the city to fill the demand
each new tavern you make an open makes
it more difficult to manage them all
he began enacting policies that make it
easier for you to keep track of how many
taverns are being run the taverns all
start to become bland and uninteresting
places to be but since you have a
monopoly you're still making ridiculous
amounts of money well that's that's
boring
yaagh changed you probably for the
better with the town being rebuilt you
eventually decide to retake your role as
a doctor in hospital there you make
friends with another doctor the two of
you do everything together
you're inseparable eventually he decide
to get an apartment and live with each
other then your friend gets married and
everything changes the spouse has to
move away through a new town and your
friend follows try to keep in touch by
mail but the letters start to come less
and less frequently you try to
fraternize with the other doctors while
they're all nice people nothing can
compare well that's sad
well I said well I'm sad now I was happy
about the rebuilding but both of those
were kind of sad the rebuilding was
optimistic but the people that were
doing it
let way lead sad lives well man house
crazy
that was like a short 15 minute
experience that I really loved
I felt attached to those people I felt
part of that how did I do that in 15
minutes I love that and I bet I'm
willing to bet every place there's going
to be a little bit different I mean sure
you can play to the point where you get
every single possibility but I bet every
play throughs going to be different so
I'm gonna leave this one the way it is
I'm gonna let my playthrough be what it
is but this game is cool like
legitimately cool just the kind of all
the possibilities that could happen and
also seeing that how the decisions kind
of echo through because she lived a life
a party and doesn't remember stuff and
then she ends up being forgotten and the
guy I don't know I the only went to
bartend one that was his first thing and
so he went back again I guess and made a
lot of money but money wasn't what it
was all about anyway and became boring
because of it kuba and I love the music
so either way I'll end this here I'll
stop blabbering about my feelings about
this and let me know what you guys think
down the comments below I really want to
hear you pins about this if you played
this before how different how many ways
are there to go about go anyway thank
you everybody so much for watching and
as always I will see you he's an
excellent bye bye
[Music]